Bin's on fire inside the courtyard of
the Chinese consulate in Houston
witnesses said they could smell paper
being burned the first whiff of a bigger
story because as firefighters arrived
chinese state media started reporting
the u.s. had ordered the consulate to be
closed it's a political provocation
unilaterally launched by the US side
which seriously violates international
law basic norms governing international
relations and the bilateral consular
agreements between China and the US
China strongly condemns such an
outrageous move in a statement the US
State Department said it would not
tolerate violations of our sovereignty
and intimidation of our people the u.s.
directive comes a day after two Chinese
nationals were charged with hacking said
to be working as spies they're accused
among other things of trying to steal
coronavirus vaccine research campaign
targeted intellectual property and
confidential business information held
by the private sector including kovin 19
related treatment testing and vaccines
back in Houston this was as close as
firefighters could get to the consulate
they weren't allowed in Chinese
officials have 72 hours to get out with
China threatening to close u.s.
consulates in response the fire may have
been put out but the us-china
relationship is smoldering as much as
ever
let's speak to tyson Barker from the
Truman National Security Project here in
Berlin Tyson what more do we know about
why the US has taken this step well
clearly this is an escalatory step on
the part of the u.s. and we don't
exactly know the reasons they have not
the u.s. is not given exact reasons what
we do know is the kind of atmospherics
around this the US has unsealed a an
indictment the Department of Justice on
Tuesday involving two Chinese hackers
that have been infiltrating research
centers looking into kovat 19 vaccines
the as you mentioned earlier Mike Pompeo
is doing a trip through Europe he was
just in the UK pushing for other
countries to ban Huawei so the
relationship attention and relationship
is growing where does this leave
diplomatic ties between the two
countries they're they're extremely
fraught right now I think when you look
at the kind of global landscape China
and the United States are criss-crossing
allies partners pushing for partners to
take a tougher stance visa be the other
the Chinese have become quite aggressive
here in Europe for example with what
they're calling a wolf warrior diplomacy
pushing partners to allow walkway for
example to take part to participate in
5g infrastructure development in places
like Germany it's it's quite tense and
and in the United States this idea of
you know a great power conflict with
China has has credibility has is getting
credence in a bipartisan way there's a
lot of support for this in Congress as
well now do you think that the Trump
administration is also hardening its
position on China given that we are in
an election year well you know there is
obviously a political overtone to this
the Trump campaign has made a point of
saying that the Trump President Trump is
is tougher on China that that Joe Biden
is soft on China that he was supportive
of you know integrating China into
global trade system for example in the
90s and early 2000s that he has a record
that doesn't match well with with
Trump's record it's not clear that
that's gonna work the rhetoric coming
out of the Biden campaign is very
similar to the Trump rhetoric and a lot
of the support for toughening sanctions
measures in the Senate and House which
are moving right now banning tick tock
for example on federal devices that's
all coming from the Democrats as well as
the Republicans Tyson Barker from the
Truman National Security Project in
Berlin thank you so much thank you
you